[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we were
discussing a
rather mathematical looking theorem uh
called the generalization of
castigliano's theorem of least work but
that had mostly to do with the modified
form of the
or modified definition of the
complementary energy
and we had said that that proof would
pave the way
for something rather useful uh
the in fact the most useful thing from
this chapter and energy methods
are called the castigliano's theorem
okay so we are going to discuss that
in this in this lecture in fact uh all
of our discussions starting from the
from the first lecture of energy methods
we have been building up towards this
particular theorem
okay so this is the famous castiglianus
theorem of
deflections classical theorem on
deflections
all right so again
instead of writing out a grand formal
statement of this castigliano's theorem
which of course is very much present in
our lecture notes
let me just try to describe what this
theorem is telling us and then
and then we'll discuss something about
the proof okay
so as usual we consider the general
three-dimensional body
okay let me use a different color again
this general three-dimensional body and
just
as in the previous uh discussion we had
we considered a part of the surface over
which the tractions were specified so
also we'll discuss
here so over this entire surface
uh but we'll of course change this a
little bit here
okay so over this entire surface the
tractions are specified
okay tractions are specified over here
and over the rest of it
uh let's say this blue color
we specify that over the rest of it
which is s2 it is the displacements
which is specified
okay now uh the only difference from
that previous consideration here
is that over this part of s1 there will
be
certain uh spots okay let's just call
spots
for now over the spots uh
together so let's say uh
let me use a different color here maybe
this one green
uh so over this little spot here
uh maybe not such a wise choice of color
here
but anyway uh over this spot here and
over this part here
over the spot here some uh some point
forces are acting okay so
something like this
okay now ideally you would think that
these point forces should be acting on
points
but as we'll discuss as part of the
proof uh
is that these these point forces are
really a manifestation of
a very concentrated distribution of
forces so
in that sense these are acting on
certain spots
and the entire area so to speak that is
covered by these spots
that will say all these green colored
things
together uh
let me not point arrows you're only
confusing
so over these these green things they
are together will constitute s naught
okay so uh so this s naught it only
pertains to these green spots okay
i don't know how this how well this
video will get rendered
but anyway uh
so these are the the green spots over
which
the the point forces are acting these
are together s naught
all right so uh so you understand that
when i write this
s one it basically excludes all these
spots
okay so this is s one uh the part of
s which does not include s naught which
does not include s2
that is s1 okay so with this much of an
understanding
what this theorem castiglione theorem of
deflections is telling us
is that uh if you wish to find out uh
and before before i state that one very
important point is that
over this s2 i have said that the
displacements is specified
but as a very special case you note that
such displacements
are specified as a special case to be
zero
okay this is very very important uh
so as as a as an example of this maybe
you can consider
something like uh like a cantilever beam
okay okay cantilever beam
under hip load so here
over this part of the cantilever
at this end the displacements are
specified but they are specified to be
zero
okay here is the point force and over
the rest of it you have zero traction
over the rest of the body you have zero
traction
so that zero traction is also something
specified let's say
okay so in that sense and you can have
other such uh more
uh more plain examples from our
engineering
perspective okay uh for now i'll delete
this and we'll go in on to such
considerations
of teams uh when we apply this
constituent theorem of uh
on deflections later on but uh
for now we we just want to discuss some
of the details of it
so what the customer's theorem of on
deflections is telling us is that
the deflection that will occur at the
points of applications of these forces
these various forces uh in the direction
of the applied force okay this is very
very important
so what we wish to say is that the
deflection of a particular force
okay in the direction of that force
that will be given by the partial
derivative
of the complementary energy
with respect to f where f
is any one of these point forces
now before launching into any detailed
discussion
it is extremely important to note that
you should think about the
you should think about
these point forces in a slightly
different
fashion from uh from the way that these
fractions and displacements are
specified
what i mean to say is that
when i say that i have specified
this traction vector the first variation
of that is
going to be 0 but you note that
if you were to consider the forces
these point forces these green colored
point forces
to be similarly specified then
considering a partial derivative with
that as the with the magnitude of that
as the independent variable
that would certainly not make any sense
so what we are saying here is that
you consider these point forces to be
variable
and we wish to find out what will be the
values of the displacements
in response to those variable forces of
course it does not mean
that you will not be able to solve
concrete problems and is we'll see that
we will be very much
able to do that but uh in the
application of carcinoma on deflections
it will be important to take them in a
very general
variable kind of fashion and then
at the end uh to to specialize them to
their specific values
so all these things will be cleared as
we go into the more details of the
casting
theorem and finally everything will we
should be crystal clear
when we come to the actual application
of this classical theorem on deflections
problems now for some uh for some of the
details of this
theorem uh regarding this proof
so fair warning first of all
uh as you may have noticed there will be
a few
things to be extremely careful about and
all throughout the proof uh you may feel
a little bit dissatisfied with certain
uh with certain critical junctures
but uh as i said fair warning so brace
yourself
uh and even before we start the proof we
have to go
go into a little uh pre-theorem kind of
thing
uh which is referred to as the theorem
of the mean for integrals okay so it
sounds like the mean value theorem which
you studied in your uh
i think in your high school maths uh you
know plus two maths
uh but uh uh but it's not
exactly that okay it's something
different the theorem for the mean for
integral this is something which we will
require
very much as part of our proof of this
cast you know theorem
on deflections so instead of digressing
in midway through the proof let me just
state it beforehand and later on i'll
just use it
and please note that i'll i'll state
this theorem uh without any proof okay
we can go
we could have gone into a detail into
the details of it but that's just
a a distraction for our current purposes
so i'll resist the temptation
so first of all uh a free
theorem kind of thing so
pardon this kind of a nomenclature but
it's just to
keep things uh
nice and simple okay so what we are what
we say is that
uh suppose you have two functions
nice real continuous functions i should
say that
f of x y and g of x y
okay defined over some area a
and you have this kind of an
integration over the area a where you
have
f of x f of x y multiplied with g of
x y over the entire area
so now what this theorem uh
theorem of the mean for integrals in
fact i can write that okay so this is
theorem
theorem of the mean for integrals
so this thing is going to be equal to
a times
g of x y d a provided
even before that let me just see what k
is
where k
is some value
[Music]
of this
a function f of x y
within the area a it is some value okay
so f of x y may take various values
within a
so what this is thing what this thing is
telling us is that it will be equal to k
times this where k is some value of f of
f of x y within a and this thing can be
written
provided
g of x y and this is the crucial thing
to note that g of x y
uh it does not change sign in a
so always you will not be able just
because you have two functions over
a over an area it does not mean that you
will be able to write it like this
of course not uh so provided
g of x y does not change sign within
a okay so it it cannot be that one
at some places within a g of x y is
positive and in other places within a
g of x y is negative no if it is
positive somewhere
it should be positive everywhere within
a if it is negative somewhere it should
be negative all
all throughout it only then this this
theorem will hold
okay so this is the theorem of the mean
for integrals and we are going to use
this
in our proof of castigliano's theorem on
deflections
okay so
we launch into the proof now and
please note the pitfalls and the special
things that i had mentioned earlier
okay so we are going to consider this f
as something variable
and which we'll actually use uh we'll
also use uh
uh we'll also use the understanding that
this f is actually generated also
through some kind of tractions but which
are
distributed over very small spots uh
and so let's let's proceed
and uh and even though we had mentioned
earlier that
uh the what we had discussed in the
previous lecture that
the modified uh complementary energy uh
the theorem associated with it to
uh which will help it will help us in
this theorem castigliano's theorem on
deflections
but it is not that we are absolutely
going to start from the expression
uh the first variation of capital psi is
equal to zero we're not going to start
from that
rather the proof of that earlier theorem
is going to help us
so uh so there are some
some if there's some careful business
involved so
let's let's give it a try okay
what we'll start with is uh if we just
look back a little bit
you see uh somewhere around here
okay we were we had started with this
delta u dash
uh and we had ultimately arrived
uh not ultimately intermediately we had
arrived
at this expression integration of ui
delta ti ds okay
over the entire surface so our
point of attack for the casting for the
proof of the castigliano's theorem of on
deflections
will be from this part and not from the
ultimate statement which you which we
had proved
here okay we are not going to start from
here rather we are going to start from
that intermediate step
okay so
we have this delta u dash is equal to
integration over the entire surface ui
delta ti d s
and as before we subdivide this
integration
over uh
over the s naught on which the point
forces so to speak at acting
but please note that the meaning
of writing this ti is that
those point forces are actually
generated to a concentrated distribution
of the of subtraction okay
you really don't have uh physically
a such a mathematically defined point
force
okay up
next over s1 we have this ui
delta ti ds
and over s2 again we have ui
delta ti ds now we take
these things so you see over s1
we do indeed have the traction specified
and
at the very beginning of our discussion
i had
carefully noted that we should be making
a distinction
between the way that the tractions are
specified over s1 and the tractions are
specified over
s naught okay so there is no question
of variability in the tractions because
they are indeed
specified in a constant fashion over s1
so here this thing is going to be 0
because ti is actually specified there
over
s1 this is extremely important to note
next for this integration over s2
it is the ui which is specified okay you
can go back
to our initial statement here when you
note that this u vector is equal to zero
it is the displacement is specified
but the value is uh is specified as zero
so here it is this thing
which is actually zero all right so what
we are really left with
is just this integration over the s
naught
so s not mind you is those little green
spots
over which the point forces are being
applied
and again i'm telling you that these
point forces are generated
through some concentric distribution of
these fractions
now uh
what we would like to do right away is
to apply
our free theorem that theorem we had
discussed
in the previous slide the theorem on of
the mean for integrals
that we are going to utilize right away
on this integration
you see that one was defined over a
certain area this is also defined over a
certain area s naught
so and there also we had two functions f
of x
x y and g of x y here also we have two
functions uh ui
and this delta t i this is this is
involving a first
uh variation but no matter so what we
the
the the starting point of our logic
uh or our argument of utilizing that
theorem
of the mean for integrals is this
that over this little spots we do not
expect
the tractions to change in sign
okay so
over the little region over the little
region
is not
we do not
expect e i
to change sine
in fact you can write this as delta t i
okay
so in that sense this delta t i is like
the
counter part of the g of x y in that
theorem
which means that we can
write this delta u dash
as ui
we take this outside but note that
the value that we specify for this thing
is
actually is not actually the ui that we
are taking out
rather a certain value
of this ui within the region
s naught
so just like in the statement of the
theorem
of the mean for integrals uh we had
taken out
a certain value k of f of x y
where k was anywhere any any
certain value within that region
similarly this ui
bar is a certain value of the ui
function within the region s naught
okay so
we write this clearly
as where ui bar are the components
of the displacement vector
ui at some point within s naught
at which point we don't bother
but at some point sorry about that
at some point
within s naught okay
now we are left with this integration
over this
delta t i all right so let me go to the
next
stage here and note that
for this so-called point force okay so
uh for uh
for this
for a point force of
fi okay
we'll have f i
as we have been seeing all along this f
i is actually generated
due to this distribution of traction
vectors
okay so you can you can think
of it like this if you if you're
uncomfortable with the
the fact that uh i have i have written
this s naught to depict
the collection of spots and here i am
writing for each
force this s naught so you can maybe say
this is s naught 1
and then maybe for another force that
could be s naught two and all those
things
but i'm not over complicating the
notation uh
you understand you're all engineers so i
i'm sure that
you're practical minded enough to
understand what's going on here
okay so so for example if you just take
one point force
it will resolve all your doubts here and
we can
easily extend that by some uh
some change of notation to more point
forces okay but that's not the point
here the point here is that
uh we would like to
arrive at an expression that we were
developing earlier
in terms of this fi okay
so towards that end we
write like this and then of course we
can write this as
as we have done earlier we take the
first variation within the integration
sign
okay which means that
whatever we had earlier obtained
this delta u dash that can be written
as ui bar
please do not forget this part this is
very very important if it's not ui
this is a specific value of ui within
some point of uh some point within that
s naught that little area s naught
so uh this entire thing can be written
as delta
f okay so now we are getting closer and
closer to our ultimate statement of the
caustic illness theorem on deflections
what we'll do is uh we know that this
delta f5 is very much
a force vector and being a vector
we can write of this
f i as
the magnitude of f okay please note that
it is this magnitude which will
ultimately
come into picture in our ultimate
statement of the of the castigliano's
theorem and deflections you know that
del del f was there
okay in that in that original statement
that that f
is this f the magnitude of the force
okay
so that multiplied by the
unit vector along f okay so this is just
like
saying that if you have any vector v
okay so that is the magnitude of that v
the vector times the the unit
normal sorry
is the unit normal or the unit vector
along the
force along that vector so in an in same
fashion we write like this
okay uh so we we know this and
so what we can say is that
delta u dash is
ui bar
ni delta
f please note that
this ui and this ni
this together is like a dot product
okay now what
what will that uh what would be the
result of that product what will be the
meaning of that
the meaning of that okay so if we
actually write
so this is a vector this is a vector we
have a dot product the result will be
some scalar
so that scalar
the the meaning of that scalar is
basically
that you see this is some displacement
uh vector at a particular point within s
naught
and if we take the uh so the meaning of
this scalar result
will be just the component
of this vector of this displacement
vector
along that n direction i repeat
if i write the result like this it
basically means
that we have taken the component of this
ui bar vector along the
direction of this unit vector but what
is the direction of this unit vector it
is nothing
but the direction of this point force
itself
because that is what it is depicting
which means ultimately what we have
written here
is that we have written the
component of the displacement vector
at a certain point within s naught
in the direction of the applied force
that is acting over that over that spot
okay so you pause for a moment here and
think about what i just said
this is the crucial statement the rest
of it is just mathematical juggling to
arrive at the final statement
but this is the heart and soul of this
theorem
okay so delta u dash we have managed to
write it
as a as a product
of two things first is this displacement
vector
up at a point within the s naught but
taken in the direction it its component
taken
in a direction along the applied point
force
multiplied with by this first variation
of the magnitude of that
point force now uh
we are almost at the end but before that
we have to take a little
leap of faith in writing something
for this delta u dash so you understand
that all throughout our discussions of
this chapter whether we are talking
about internal energy strain energy
specifically
specifically strain energy complementary
we had in our brain that
somehow these had connections with the
strains and
stresses now what i want you to think is
that
this strain here uh whatever it may be
within the body uh manifested in terms
of the deformations and everything
that is ultimately occurring as a result
of the application of this force
and also you note that we are
considering
very much the variability variability of
this
force so is it not possible
to write a connection directly between
this
complementary energy with the variation
of that force okay so earlier we had
written things like del u
dash l epsilon
p q and sort of things those kinds of
things
what i want you to now think is that
directly we want to make a connection
between this u dash and the force which
is
variable because the strains that are
being generated in the body the
strains represent the deformations those
deformations are actually brought about
in response to these
uh to these forces so what we write here
is that
this is del u dash del f
delta f okay and again mind you
that suppose there were some dependence
on temperature or things like that
we would have to add terms here to write
things like plus del u dash
del t delta t and so on and so forth
suppose if there was some dependence on
the electric field and things like that
would have to keep on adding terms but
we don't have those complications here
so we just stop here write it like this
now if you compare this one and this one
okay so uh maybe i
i call this as three
here and hash four
so comparing
uh maybe i write this in the next
comparing hash p
and dash 4
we have delta u uh sorry
we have uf r
the component of the displacement uh
along the
direction f to be equal to
del u dash del f and this
is nothing but our original statement
uh for the castigliano's theorem of
inflection so it is
it's proved here okay so
the path to this had been uh
i mean it has been visited with a very
careful remarks and statements
uh but i hope this will give you some
sort of satisfaction and then that we
have
managed to arrive at this thing and it
is in this form that we are directly
going to
apply it to problems now
one very important note is that
if our material behavior is such
that it is linear elastic then there is
no difference between the complementary
energy and the strain energy
okay so for linear elastic materials
that is
for hookian kind of materials linear
elastic materials
okay so u dash is equivalent to u
and for those things we can directly
write
uh uf bar is equal to
l u l f
and it is this particular form of
which is mostly used used
in in many undergraduate textbooks
if they do deal with energy methods so
most
many undergraduate textbooks they don't
deal with energy methods but
there's some good textbooks which do use
and when they do
uh mostly it is in this fashion
that they write the displacement in
terms of
the directly in terms of the derivative
of the
strain energy and not in terms of the
complementary energy
but you see that or
i i should make a remark here that this
is certainly not true
for non-linear materials or
for non-linear material behavior
this is very very important to note
and we will see an example of this okay
uh so with that as far as the theory
part of
this energy methods is concerned we are
done
uh so we will discuss
problems you also do some problems all
right with that i
end this lecture thank you very much